Gut, gleichesgeles, gleiche Technik, einfach nur mit einem Richtigungswechsel, die sogenannte Prüfungs 8 oder aber Prüfung mit P2 bezeichnet.
Da ist es so, auch da beginnen wir auf eine Achse, wir fliegen einen komplett geschlossenen Links-Kreis, also an der Prüfung wird immer mit dem Links-Kreis begonnen.
Dann auf unserer Achse kommt direkt an hing in der Rechtskreis.
Das heißt, die zwei Kreise sind ein bisschen versetzt von den anderen geflogen auf einer Leitlinie und deshalb sagt man den Prüfungs 8,
weil das wie so von der verschobene Acht aussieht, hat nichts mit der geschriebenen Achts zu tun, sind zwei vollständig geschlossene Kreise.
Achtet auch darauf, dass wenn ihr die Achse erreicht habt, also auf Fluchzeit der direkte Wechsel kommt,
ihr müssten nicht gerade ausfliegen, dieser Leitlinie und dann kommt ein We
und probiert beides aus und lehnt das was euch besser gefällt.
Präums am Stech suchen wir beizeit das geringste Sinken, mit checken den Luftraum ist der Luftraum 3, kommt der Links-Kreis,
die Gewicht links rein, rechte Hand ganz rauf.
Kurz, bevor wir auf unserer Flucht sind, kommt schon das Körpergewicht, dann auf unserer Flucht die Bremse und dann kommt der direkte Wechselzack in den Rechtskreis.
Dann beenden wir den Rechtskreis fast vollständig, kurz bevor wir auf dem Trax sind, geht der Körper in die neutrale Sitzposition und gleichzeitig entspannt,
also zieht die Außenbremse immer langsam, gut voll, kommt dann die Außenbremse so, dass wir beizeitig angebremst aus diesem Ganzen herauskommen.
Auch da ist erst einmal wichtig nicht die Zeit, sondern einfach Flucht, Flucht und das gleiche gilt immer auch für den Doppelkreis.
Flucht ist erst einmal wichtig Orientierung im Raum, einstellende Klärlage, Körperverlagung und so weiter.
Die Zeit kommt dann später. Je mehr wir das Ganze präniert haben, umso wohler fühlen wir uns dann, wenn die Klärlage ein bisschen mehr eingestellt wird
und es gehen wir in die neutrale Sitzposition und zack, nehmen die Außenbremse mit, so dass wir wieder angebremst herauskommen.
Sobald wir das haben, dürfen wir dann die Bremse auch wieder vollständig freien.
Bei der 8 basiert das oft, dass man den ersten Kreis ziemlich zügig einleitet.
Dann kommt der Wechsel vor und man macht mehrheitlich fast den Minover auf diese Seite und verrungen dann,
so nach dem ersten Imput, also achtet darauf, dass ihr direkt beim Wechsel auch mit der Außenbremse arbeitet.
Gedeutet, wenn ich jetzt hier reingehe, zack, kurz bevor ich auf meiner Flucht bin, kommt die Außenhand mit dem Gewicht harmonisch,
so dass ich eigentlich auf meiner Haße beizeitig gebremst bin und dann kommt der harmonische Direkt der Wechsel.
Aber da wieder immer Pandäten außenbremst. Das Außenbremse ist ein wichtiges Element beim Kreischen fliegen.
Sollten wir mal in einer Spirale enden, beist mir es weisse oder einfach beim Doppelkreis in einer sehr starken Querlage.
Werden wir nie die innenhand freigeben, sondern mit hin.
Über die Außenbremse soweit nach unten bis mir gerade rauskommen aus dem Ganzen.
Das ist ein ganz wichtiges Element und darum geht es.
Für das Manöver 8 wird eine vorgegebene Fluggagse eingenommen.
Durch dosiertes Ziehen der linken Steuerleine wird ein Links-Kreis geflogen, bis der Schirm wieder auf der ursprünglichen Fluggagse.
Mit dosiertem Ziehen der rechten Steuerleine wird anschließend ein Rechtskreis geflogen, bis der Schirm wieder auf der ursprünglichen Fluggagse ist.
Durch dosiertes Anbremsen, nachfolgende Roll- und Nickbewegungen abgefangen und der Schirm stabilisiert.
Vorsicht!
Beim Richtungswechsel können zu starkes Ziehen der Steuerleine oder falsches Timing zu einem einseitigen Strömungsabres führen.
Die Zeitdauer für das Manöver beträgt maximal 25 Sekunden. Wichtig!
Die Zeitmessung stoppt erst, wenn der Schirm stabil auf der ursprünglichen Fluggagse fliegt.